you're familiar with the fear greed
index you ever heard about that yes so
every
month they sort of calculate the
sentiment of the country so when it
comes to money you can either be greedy
or fearful warren buffett has basically
said be greedy when people are fearful
or be fearful when people are greedy
over the last few years during
covid everyone's been greedy they're
printing money crypto's going crazy the
stock market's going crazy everyone
looks like a freaking genius right now
oh i bought an nft for 100 grand it's
worth a million but everyone's being
greedy now if you look at the fear greed
index right now i haven't actually seen
it in a few months the last time i
looked at it it was closer to greed we
are now in a time of
extreme
fear so what does this mean
obviously like i said before pat
if you if like right i'm because i've
saved that money and i've just been very
calculated and i haven't gone and ball
out and bought a lamborghini over the
last few years i could have but i'm like
you know what save save save save save
save when i've had the opportunity to
buy a sick pad i'm like you know what
let me just rent when i've had an
opportunity to buy a dope watch i'm like
let me buy a bitcoin what have you now
if you've got your house in order now's
a great time to be greedy so were you
following everybody's fear so you were
fear so technically you were fearful not
to agree not me i but my my fear was for
what could happen here got you like
again if you've got like so i don't have
pvd money but i'm doing all right okay
like if i get another zero or so i'll be
on pbs level but i've got some zeros but
it all depends on your age and like
where you're at in life but
so let me ask you a question just you
know average person listening to this
right now
let's say they're either living paycheck
to paycheck or they're living a little
better than paycheck to people they hear
all of this stuff and all they zero in
on is what can i do sure all they see is
their prices are going up they can't
they can't even get in the car to drive
to the grocery store and put gas in
their car without it being a problem
everything is becoming a problem at the
most basic levels for these people so
they're saying to themselves they feel
very powerless in situations like this
they don't have a lot of other options
maybe they didn't have an opportunity to
save a bunch of money so they're sitting
on limited options limited choices right
now
so
can they do anything and how much of who
wins the next election
has to do with this in other words let's
say biden is out somebody else is in how
much is affected when it comes to these
deep financial topics that people
honestly don't oftentimes have time to
dig into major leagues so what does it
look like let's say it's not biden well
let's say it's it's desantis let's say
it's trump paint a different picture
well let me explain to what happened so
last year
not last year 2015 2016 when it was
between hillary and
trump
and wall street experts came out
and they said we're getting behind
hillary hillary's winning okay
when that announcement was made the
market tanked for a while okay i don't
know if you guys remember this the
market tank so i'm in the business where
i saw the market tank because everybody
was bracing for impact with what with
hillary okay
but then the day trump won
under obama's administration the last 60
days of obama being president the next
day the market blew up
if you just go look at go november 4th
whatever the day is november 3rd
november 14th of 2016.
and matter of fact just pull up november
2016 stock market that's all i want you
to pull up 2016 stock market november
okay
uh uh go to it go uh uh no go back
go back and and see if you can get the
whole month
see if you can get the whole month
anyways you look for this you'll see
the day okay is that it
okay look at that look at that look at
that right there wow look look when the
elections are
drops concerned boom it goes up the next
couple months because it's the trump
effect
people knew that guy knows how to drive
the economy okay so so so the day
biden was announced that he is look what
happened to the market same thing so you
can the market knows what's going to
happen the market knows what's going to
take place
uh the moment he got in and he said he's
going to do what he did with oil right
off the bat in january february when he
made that decision and it was a big
pivotal moment to the election where
trump said okay hey oil people texas
listen to what he just said he warned
everybody you're going to pay the price
for this it's very simple
when i was coming up in my early 20s and
all i'm thinking about is i got to make
money to retire my dad from working at
that 99 cent store in englewood that was
the only thing on my mind i'm like i
gotta retire my sister's gonna go on a
nice honeymoon and i gotta pay off my 49
thousand dollars of debt those were my
three main goals that i had right i
didn't pay attention to politics i
didn't give a [ __ ] about who's doing
what i didn't even understand policies
capital i didn't know none of this stuff
okay i didn't want to deal with it
because politics my parents got a
divorce i don't want to deal with any of
that stuff
then all of a sudden i made money
and i said you better pay attention to
this stuff
because you can't just go the rest of
your life like you know sometimes people
like in the world of business they'll
say things like i'm the vision i had a
guy that i went to in long beach i was
consulting with this guy he says i'm the
visionary i don't deal with the minutia
i pulled him aside i said i said you can
never say something like that if you're
the ceo the founder of this company
because you have to know the minutia or
else you don't know how to manage and
drive the minutiae so if somebody wants
to be wealthy but you don't want to pay
attention to the economy and the market
you're contradicting yourself if you
want to create wealth you have to shift
the way you look at the economy and the
market because policies have a massive
effect i hope if if the last you know
five six years from 2015 to 10 to now i
hope if the last six seven years did
anything it got people to pay attention
to policies more closely because it
directly impacts your kids
and who do you love more than your kids
your political party no hopefully it's
your kids if you love your kids more
than your political party start paying
attention to what's going on with these
policies because their future is relying
on how you vote very simple that's what
i was just getting at too because these
people that feel powerless i'm always
like there's power in your vote you can
do something and what i hate is people
sitting at home reading these stories
and feeling like it's out of my hands i
can't do anything no matter what i do i
don't have the finances to really make a
big difference but if you know that you
go to the voting booth and that has a
big effect and that has a ripple effect
out and that has the potential to create
better policies for the economy at large
people feel powerful i hate when people
feel proud i'm going to give you guys a
totally different perspective here and i
do agree with pat but that's on a macro
perspective like
i don't give a [ __ ] how you vote if
you're not working and saving and
getting out of debt i don't give a [ __ ]
what policies you agree with because
your house is drowning so let me address
your questions specifically i don't care
if you've like i've made money under
biden i've made monday under trump i've
made money under obama
don't care okay but what i'll tell you
is this if like because i do appreciate
what he's saying exactly the policies
printing money that that is a thing like
that from a macro perspective 100
but also you need to look in the mirror
and you need to say all right cool
uh there's a big difference between
wants and needs
and what happens is when your
wants kind of become your needs and you
and you and you and you develop what's
called lifestyle creep i was making 50.
now i'm making 70. so
time for me to get a nicer apartment i
was making a hundred now i'm making 150.
i feel time for me to know i feel safe
time for me to get a nicer car
no i tell people all the time okay you
got a 20 raise save that money so it's
on you like so i also say this there's a
big difference between poor and broke if
you're poor
and you're a single mother with two kids
with two jobs
there's nothing you can do
okay there's nothing you could do get
smarter read more like like you're not
gonna make more money but most people
are not poor most people are broke they
make 50 grand a year and they spend 55.
but so that's a question patrick so but
and here's my thing and going off what
you what you said
the
everybody says it's happening and under
joe biden my thing is why why are they
doing it and i saw something yesterday
where they're like they've been trying
to get rid of the middle class all these
policies all these things and it's
actually working i understand what
you're saying but those people that are
trying and hustling and doing their
thing that those people in the middle
it's going to be either you're rich as
hell or you're poor and that's and
that's where it's going and nobody and
it drives me crazy because a lot of
these like polls and these stats and
percentages to like 50 percent of people
you know i think that it's going bad so
does that mean 50 of the world of
americans are like yeah
this is good it looks not good i don't
necessarily
agree like at the end of the day you
need to look in the mirror and you need
to take accountability for yourself okay
like that
i
i had to take two years of my life
sacrifice
make you know how it is when you start
off in financial sales you need to eat
[ __ ] for a couple years but i went in i
was a [ __ ] party boy in south beach i
was having a great time having a time of
my life making zero money and i said you
alright i can continue down this path of
having a great time and just crashing on
friends couches or i could eat [ __ ] for
a couple years buckle down
learn a trade have a specific undeniable
inflation-proof skill set and for the
next 15 years i'm gonna make money
that's true but the jobs need to exist
so when you're talking about that you
know single mom and she's sitting at
home with her kid and you were saying
you know she doesn't have a lot of
options there's not a lot she can do
well there is a lot she can do she can
get a second job potentially a lot of
people dig themselves out of that hole
but those opportunities need to exist so
if you're living in an economy where
people are firing instead of hiring
because they can't afford it where
you're living in an economy where
minimum wage and policies like that come
into effect and they prevent people from
having opportunities that's yeah but
what's up what's that lady's skill set
i'm sorry if you don't have a skill
you're replaceable if you're making
fifteen dollars i don't know it doesn't
matter let's say i don't know what her
skill set is but but let's say let's say
it's minimal she can still get a second
job she can still do something she can
still do something there are people who
climb from the very bottom of the bottom
up but those opportunities have to exist
in the society they live in yeah because
if you go out and you want to get a
second job and there are no second jobs
because no one's hiring because the
economic climate sucks you're in trouble
that's when you're really i hear you
i guess about savings
i'm
you know what we're in america here
go to any other place in the world and
give that little spiel they'll be like
i'm just trying to survive
we're still in america here we're still
the greatest superpower in the world
still to this day you know knock on wood
hopefully china doesn't surpass us
anytime soon it might happen but still
like look where you are in the world god
bless america and god bless the fact
that you could choose and to become
whatever you want in this life and you
could always i'm not saying that you are
but you can always play the victim role
the economy sucks and joe biden and gasp
but at some point victim that's just
reality yeah if people are not hiring
and you're looking and you're grinding
and you're hustling i mean i know people
right now trying to find work that are
having a really hard time their skills
what they do over the last three years
though some of them got fired because
they wouldn't get a jab and now they're
stuck i mean there's a lot of lockdowns
look what they did i know people who
start work their whole life to start
businesses in a place like new york city
build that business up feeling great
lock down they can't handle being closed
for three months they pick up they have
to go to a new city they have kids to
support people are in circumstances now
that we haven't seen in a really long
time all i'm saying is that
if you if you have someone at the very
top of the heap that's not that's not
creating policies that trickle
opportunity down and people ha people
feel like they have limited options
that's going to decrease their ability
to climb out of a hole no question no
matter how motivated they are or not
these policies do have an effect on
individuals that macro hits the micro if
you're a small business i one thousand
percent agree with you but most people
aren't small business owners how many
small businesses are in america adam i
will tell you both of you guys are right
here's what's crazy but
both of you are right you're right and
she's right okay
this is a documentary that came out in
2008.
uh it was with david walker the former
comptroller general of the u.s i i have
i brought him out to an event in 2011.
uh he he's like the the cfo of america
is who he was for like 10 or 12 years
okay david walker there's a scene in it
which is powerful
a lady who's a single mother asks warren
buffett hey uh uh what do i do i'm this
i'm in this situation i'm going through
this financially i'm going through that
what do i do to change my life right now
because i don't know how to come out of
this he sits there and says look it's
not going to be pretty it's going to be
ugly but here's what i will tell you go
increase your market value that's what
you need by the way this is o8 so if you
remember oh wait by the way if you
haven't seen this documentary go see it
because it pretty much shows what we're
about to go through it breaks it down
exactly what we're about to go through
this documentary breaks on i o usa with
david walker first time i was introduced
to this guy was by a couple named dean
and fliss who are very successful
financial folks but uh so you're right
regardless it's your responsibility to
go out make to make money and do
something with it but she's right
everything rises and falls on leadership
leaders policies affect people's lives
so it's kind of like saying well no
matter how bad of a father you had you
can still go out there and make it
you're right but hey people with better
fathers they have a really big impact on
kids lives you're right do you get what
i'm saying so yes everyone everyone has
a difficult starting point there is
truth in both and we have to keep
pushing both messages do something with
your life can we have better policies
that's right i think both ways we need
to help well that and to go back to your
point i said pat gave you the macro
perspective policies fed interest rates
listen there's things that matter
and there's things that you can control
you need to focus on where those two
things intersect things that matter and
things that you can control breaking
news you're not going to control infra
interest rates you're not going to do it
no matter what you do you're but you can
control all right cool i made five grand
this month how much i'm gonna spend them
on rent how much i'm gonna do in a car
payment by the way it's summer
everyone's planning on going on vacation
right by the way everyone just got their
tax refund you made you made you got 3
000 back from tax refund this is what i
talked about wants versus needs what are
you gonna do with that three grand
you're gonna go on vacation you're going
to mykonos yeah you're going to st parts
you're going you're going to niagara or
you're just going to you know what let
me pay off my debt this is what i'm
talking about you have choices you have
options we're still in america baby so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]